If some lenders had their way, you'd do all
your shopping on a credit card.
Why?
Because it makes them money.
Lots of it.
And to try and entice you into keep spending,
they offer rewards.
Some really, really nice rewards.
But are those rewards really worth it?
Who's being rewarded?
You?
Or your bank?
If you're careful, airline, hotel, and credit
card points can get you far.
And some people spend a tremendous amount
of time seeing exactly how far that is.
This is Brad.
And he's a bit of a ... Let's call him a credit
card connoisseur.
I decided to head down to Murray Hill to check
out his massive card collection.
This is a lot of credit cards.
Walk me through.
How many are here?
I think there is about 70, or 80 here.
How many of these are open?
I think there is about 20 to 25 that are open
right now.
How did you get into it?
How did that process begin?
I got a letter in the mail, saying you can
get ... I think it was 50,000 Delta points
for spending $3,000 in three months.
Okay.
There was no fee in the first year.
Yeah, I've gotten those.
I always toss those.
Yeah, well you should read them 'cause sometimes
you can see that if there is no fee, and you're
gonna spend that $3,000 in three months-
Yeah.
If you're doing that anyway, it's free points.
Do you know how many points you've accumulated
over the last five years?
Yeah.
What is it?
It's probably between seven and ten million
points.
Are you joking?
No.
How much time do you spend on this?
On just this, it's probably a couple hours
a week.
I have a spreadsheet that I maintain.
And there is websites that will keep track
of your loyalty accounts.
But also there is kind of research that I'm
doing.
The best general card anyone can get is just
2% cash back, no annual fee.
Okay.
At the end of the year, you get a check in
the mail.
It's just free money.
It's what you can get, and you don't have
to think about it at all.
It seems like kind of exhausting.
To someone else, it would seem like homework.
But I kind of enjoy it.
If someone wants to get into it, what would
you tell them?
What's the way to start up?
The very first thing I would tell them, is
just make sure your finances are in order.
Don't carry a balance.
Don't pay unnecessary interest.
Don't ever carry a balance?
No.
'Cause that's ... You're paying interest on
any balance that you're carrying.
Right.
That's money you're giving away.
Treat it like a debit card.
Okay.
It's money that you're spending each month,
and you pay it off immediately.
Okay.
Managing 25 open cards can be exhausting.
Done right, like Brad, you could get a lot
of free stuff.
But it's also full of traps that could expose
you to expensive fees.
Remember banks are in the business of making
money, and credit cards are one of their most
profitable activities.
Here to tell us more about how banks usually
win is Bloomberg reporter Jenny Surane.
Credit card companies, their ideal goal is
that you'll spend each month, and then you'll
pay off your bill.
Or ideally actually you'll carry a balance,
and they can charge you that interest.
When you're thinking about getting a credit
card, and using a credit card, interest is
one of the most important things to be paying
attention to.
For instance, let's say you buy a TV for $1,000.
Even if you pay off $999 of that bill, you
could still be charged interest on the whole
thing, even if you've only left a dollar on
your balance.
And credit cards sometimes come with the highest
form of interest.
If you're thinking about going and chasing
after crazy credit card rewards, you have
to be really responsible, and stay on top
of your payments.
If you're very responsible, and meticulously
organized like Brad, then you're probably
set.
If it's something where you're gonna be carrying
a balance, you probably should walk away.
Yeah, chasing points requires a lot of time
and care.
Just look at Brad.
As the old saying goes, "Make sure the juice
is worth the squeeze."